Speaker 1: Let's go to Eric from Colorado.
Eric, you're on the air.
Hey, David, this is Eric.
Hey, Eric, what's going on?
Speaker 5: Hey, so I kind of had a question,
a little bit of what the last caller said.
Where do you think that we would be if Trump
was still elected and this war was still going
on?
Speaker 1: So I'm going to be I'm not going
to.
I could give you some totally cartoonish thing
where I could say, like if Trump was president
right now, he would be literally cheerleading
Putin's invasion.
No, no, no, no.
I think here's the way I think this would
have gone down if if Trump were president
when Putin invaded Ukraine first, Trump would
have done exactly what he did in the first
couple of days.
He would have said Putin smart.
Putin savvy.
Putin's genius.
Imagine that what great land he's taking,
he would have said that at the beginning,
then the entire world, including everybody
around Trump, would have started to say, Hey,
you can't be praising Putin.
Putin's choosing to do this war of aggression,
like you got to back off of it.
And much like Trump did at CPAC.
I think Trump would have turned around and
he would have started at least softly supporting
Ukraine's defense of its land.
But but I think that when it comes to coordinating
sanctions with our allies, the way that Joe
Biden has been doing Trump would just completely
fail and the discussions would be a disaster
and we would be humiliated and out of sync
with our allies rather than under Biden.
At least you could disagree with what's being
done.
But at least it's sort of like a coherent
united plan.
I think that's what would happen under Trump.
Speaker 5: Thank you, and do you think that,
like Russia would have probably done more
if the United States would have been out of
Natal under Trump?
Speaker 1: So I mean, I don't know those hype.
I don't I don't find tons of value in those
that type of hypothetical necessarily that
that requires a lot more differences and assumptions.
I'm just not sure.
Speaker 3: OK.
Thank you so much for taking my call, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
There's Eric from Colorado with a very specific
question.
Let's go next to sir.
Is it Sir Rob from Austin?
I know we've spoken before and I think I messed
up the name last time